- I don't wanna scare the children.
(laughter)
(light banjo music)
- When was the last time you someone
walking down the street with a mustache on
who didn't look like an absolute creep?
- Burt Reynolds, that's
pretty much all I have,
actually, Burt Reynolds.
- They're all like,
pretty bold characters.
I don't consider myself a bold character.
I will look terrible with a mustache.
- I hope my girlfriend finds
me somewhat attractive.
- Gosh, I don't know, I
hope I don't look creepy.
- I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get
teased by my friends though.
- I'm doing it in front of the baby,
so I don't scare the baby, so
she knows that it's still me.
- I do not know where the mustache
is supposed to start and end.
- You think this is a good look?
Huh?
- She looks intrigued.
- Well, here it is, mustache, baby!
- I have a mustache now.
- Not too shabby.
- It's very hard to see right now.
- You should just color it in,
with like a little eyeliner.
- ♫ Oh, I got a mustache now ♫
Heard there was a video
goin' on about this,
so I'm like, I'll just see if
I can join in, so here I am.
- Annika, come check this out.
I look like a pizza delivery man?
- You just look like a different person.
- I'm getting Frenchmen, or pedophile.
- Almost like a 1970's creepy
pedophile Texan a little bit.
- No?
Does it just not look good on me?
(laughter)
Thanks, Indy.
- He could get himself a straight
woman with this mustache.
- Whoo, where's a jar?
- Chloe just walked up to me and said,
"Oh, you have a mustache",
and I said "yeah" and she was like,
"What's that all about?"
- So I'm about to hop on
an early flight to Seattle,
with this mustache, I could be the pilot.
- I've been out all day,
and no one has really
noticed, or cared, or said anything.
It's like no one really cares
that I have just a mustache.
- Cold, and it's rainy,
and my chin just feels
bare naked wet.
- My girlfriend likes it, but also admits
that she only likes it
because it makes her laugh.
- You should definitely shave it.
- So I just went through TSA,
and the TSA agent looked at my ID,
looked at me and said "Nice disguise,
I really like the glasses,
mustache, and big nose."
- So, I've had a mustache
for almost a week now,
and no one notices, ever,
I've started telling people.
- Some people just did not know
who I was when I said hi to them.
- Girlfriend hated it, my
female co-workers hated it.
- Women hate it.
- They were all like,
"You should keep it."
- No one commented on it.
My friends didn't even notice.
There's hair here.
- People were just like, that fits ya.
You get to have a mustache
when you're a dad.
- I FaceTimed by dad and he goes,
"You look like an a******."
- I don't think it's fair for girls
to be able to come up,
and ridicule my face
but if a girl gets a
certain kind of haircut,
it's a huge faux pas to comment on it.
- I can't wait to get my beard back.
- I think I'm gonna keep it.
- I definitely would rather have had
people give me negative comments
and be like "Whoa, you
should not be wearing that"
than no comments at all.
- I had my feelings hurt when people
told me they thought it looked gross.
You're surprisingly vulnerable
when you're in between looks.
(light music)
(electric razor)
- It's not coming off.